I talked to this mom and her son right
after watch the full video Gary yes you
saved my life I didn't even know what to
say I don't even know what to say I
thought I was done and you said these
words you said 50 is half time yes and I
just I was 48 I just went [__] he's
right it just is and I went from an
abusive relationship got out of it
really bad too a good place that left my
job new job I love it my kids are safe
we're all safe and it's awesome just
those words I always say the one you're
gonna hear that one thing yeah literally
saved my life in all four of my
children's lives without words such a
pleasure to see you hey Gary all right
such a pleasure same thing like just
watching your content and seeing the way
that my life has improved instantly you
know helping my connection with my mom
you know we haven't had the best of the
past sure those are challenging
circumstances a lot of circumstances but
the beauty is you have so much more time
in front of you